I have to say it again it's just so
great to be here in New York it's great
to be sorry did someone have a problem
order somebody / Prabhu sir what is your
deal what's your deal you don't have me
fooled O'Brien don't have you fooled
what are you talking about it's great to
be here in New York like you're really
here
come on of course I'm here yeah right I
know the truth I'm like the rest of
these people wake up TV's a bunch of
lies you're not in New York you're back
in some fancy Hollywood sound stage
pretending to be in New York that
doesn't make any sense where do you
where do you think you are right now oh
I'm in New York the greatest city in the
world
waiter they got bridges we got Road but
if you think but I'm in California yeah
even though we're in the same room it
looks like we're in the same room
thanks to your fancy Hollywood CGI F
trickery no no it's it's just called CGI
it's not C gif C gif computers got
eyeballs food so stupid what if I
invited you on stage wouldn't that prove
to you that I'm really here in New York
would that prove it to you maybe come on
never met a hologram before oh you're
real yeah whoa yeah yeah you convinced
Ohayou all an apology kind of called you
stupid are you real yeah I'm real I feel
like an idiot I'm really sorry okay it
happened yeah yeah yeah I got an idea
you want to go backstage hang out in the
greenroom with the cast of daddy's home
- they're all here you want - Luka yeah
yeah yeah really yeah go ahead yes get
me buddy yeah I'm coming
[Applause]
you
you